♪
>> LOOK IN THE MIRROR, YOU’RE
DOING THE SAME THING.
THE HEDGE FUNDS ARE GETTING
AGAINST COMPANIES.
WE’RE BETTING ON THEM.
WITH MONEY AND MARGIN, WE’RE
DOING THE SAME THING.
ONLY DIFFERENCE IS WE’RE WINNING
AND YOU’RE GETTING YOUR TEETH
KICKED IN.
IT’S BECAUSE THEY’RE BEING
PULLED BY STRINGS.
IT’S CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO TO JAIL!
>> Tucker: THAT, AS YOU KNOW,
WAS EARLIER IN THE SHOW, DAVE
PORTNOY WHO RUNS THE SPORTS SITE
BARSTOOL.
SOME OF THE SMARTEST ANALYSIS
WHAT WE’RE SEEING ON WALL STREET
NOW WITH FROM A GUY WITH A
SPORTS SITE.
ONE OF THE SMARTEST PIECES
WRITTEN ON THIS TODAY CAME FROM
SOMEONE WHO IS ALSO NOT STRICTLY
SPEAKING A FINANCIAL JOURNALIST.
HE COVERS FOREIGN POLICY.
GLENN GREENWALD, INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST.
HOPE YOU SUPPORT HIS WORK.
GRATEFUL TO HAVE HIM ON TONIGHT
TO EXPLAIN WHAT THIS MEANS.
YOU WROTE A GREAT PIECE THIS
TODAY, GLENN.
THERE’S SO MUCH TO SAY.
HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS WHAT WE’RE
SEEING WITH GAME STOP AND THE
HEDGE FUND?
>> THERE ARE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT POWER CENTERS IN THE
UNITED STATES, MANY OF WHICH WE
OFTEN OPENLY DISCUSS, THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, SILICON
VALLEY, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT,
LOBBYISTS.
OBVIOUSLY, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND POWERFUL, IF NOT
THE MOST POWERFUL IS WALL STREET
AND HEDGE FUNDS IN PARTICULAR ON
WALL STREET WHO ARE IN THE TOP
OF THAT FOOD CHAIN.
WE ALMOST NEVER TALK ABOUT HOW
IT IS THEY GET TO BE
MULTIBILLIONAIRES, ABOUT REALLY
PRODUCING ANYTHING OF VALUE,
JUST LEAVING OFF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY, TAKING HUGE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY IN EXCHANGE FOR NOTHING.
WHENEVER YOU THINK OF SILICON
VALLEY, THEY GET BACK BY
PRODUCING SOMETHING WHATEVER YOU
THINK OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY AGREE.
>> THESE PEOPLE DON’T PRODUCE
NOTHING.
THEY JUST TAKE.
AND THEY JUST TAKE AND THEY JUST
TAKE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, NOT ONLY ARE
WE SEEING THEM HAVE PAIN
INFLICTED ON THEM, NOT BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE STEALING FROM THEM OR
COMMITTING CRIMES BUT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE FIGURED OUT THEIR GAME AND
LEARNED HOW TO EXPLOIT IT BY
DOING WHAT THEY SHOULD DO WHICH
IS STUDYING IT BUT THEY’RE ALSO
GETTING DRAGGED OUT INTO THE
SUNLIGHT SO FOR THE FIRST TIME,
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE
MELVIN CAPITAL AND CITADEL AND
HEDGE FUND SHORT SELLERS AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY’RE DOING TO THIS COUNTRY
AND IT ONLY HAPPENED, TUCKER,
BECAUSE THE INTERNET A FREE
INTERNET -- WHEN IT’S FREE --
ENABLES CITIZENS TO BAND
TOGETHER IN LARGE ENOUGH NUMBERS
TO CHALLENGE THE RULING CLASS
ELITES.
THAT’S WHY WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT
THE IMPERATIVE NATURE OF
DEFENDING THE INTERNET FROM
SURVEILLANCE, DEFENDING IT FROM
CENSURESHIP.
IT’S A VERY POWERFUL WEAPON IN
THE HANDS OF CITIZENS AGAINST
RULING CLASS ELITES.
THAT’S WHY THEY’RE SO BENT UPON
SEIZING IT BACK, CONTROLLING IT,
REGULATING IT AND CENSURING IT.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU MAKE
SUCH A WISE POINT.
IF I MADE $1 BILLION, PEOPLE
WOULD SAY, WHERE DID YOU MAKE
$1 BILLION?
AND FOR WHAT?
I WOULD FEEL INCUMBENT UPON ME
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO EXPLAIN
WHAT I DID.
I NEVER HEAR ANYONE DISCUSS WHAT
THE UPPER ECHELONS OF FINANCE
HAVE REALLY DONE OR AS YOU
POINTED OUT CONTRIBUTED TO
BECOME BILLIONAIRES.
WHY IS THAT NOT A CONVERSATION
WE’RE HAVING ALL THE TIME?
>> RIGHT AND THE OTHER THING I
THINK IS SO INTERESTING FROM
THIS PARTICULAR CASE IS YOU SEE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT AND PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT REACTING IN VERY
SIMILAR WAYS, NAMELY IN FAVOR OF
WHAT THESE REDDITERS DID TO
THESE HEDGE FUNDS.
WHY?
BECAUSE IF YOU’RE ON THE RIGHT,
WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN GENERALLY,
TRADITIONALLY IS FREE MARKET
ECONOMICS.
IF YOU’RE ON THE LEFT, WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IN IS GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION AND THE ECONOMY TO
HELP THE NEEDIEST.
WE HAVE NEITHER OF THOSE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS A TOTALLY RED
SYSTEM WHERE THE GOVERNMENT
CONSTANTLY INTERVENES IN THE
ECONOMY BUT NOT TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN NEED BUT TO HELP THE
RICHEST AND MOST POWERFUL WHO
ARE FUNDED AND OWNED AND
CONTROLLED BY THOSE VERY RICH
PEOPLE WHO FUND THEIR CAMPAIGN
TO PAY THEIR LOBBYISTS WHO GIVE
THEM ENORMOUS SPEAKING FEES WHEN
THEY’RE OUT OF POWER AND IT’S A
SYSTEM THAT NO ONE, EITHER ON
THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT, SUPPORTS.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT IT
ARE THE ESTABLISHMENT CENTRISTS
IN BOTH WINGS OF THE PARTIES AND
THEY SEE THESE PEOPLE UNITING
AGAINST THEM AND THAT’S WHY
THEY’RE DESPERATE TO REIMPOSE A
WEDGE BETWEEN US SO THAT WE
CAN’T UNITE ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: HA-HA!